[Música]
[Aplausos]
y muy buenas tardes es un honor para mí
estar aquí y ser parte de lo que vimos
la computada
un espacio donde irán las ideas y donde
el ojo el instituto educativo ha
organizado todo para
ay qué
voy a presentar una temática
le titulado vivir para contarlo
vivir para contarlo no van a escuchar
ustedes
si hemos encontrado el camino para
encontrar la fuente de la eterna
juventud o la piedra filosofal
tampoco les voy a hablar de el dengue
tampoco les voy a hablar del cáncer y
les voy a hablar del sida les voy a
hablar de un elemento que sutilmente
puede subir en nuestro organismo y
alterarlo
si el nivel del azúcar en tu cuerpo
rebasa 100 miligramos
estás en graves problemas y es más
desastroso que la suma de todo lo que te
acabo de decir
en muchos de nuestros países la
expectativa de vida ha aumentado no
solamente por poder sonreír sino porque
la medicina ha avanzado mucho y permite
una mayor calidad en tu día a día
sin embargo si tu nivel de azúcar sube
de 100 miligramos
y no lo controlas tu expectativa de vida
se va a reducir de 15 a 20 años
y no vas a vivir para contarlo
por esa razón que nuestro méxico en los
últimos la última década hay una gran
cantidad de personas que tienen este
problema
la última encuesta hablar sobre 125
millones de personas en mexico de ellas
entre 90 y 100 millones tienen 18 años o
más
de este grupo de personas
aproximadamente 10 millones de personas
tienen el azúcar elevada
y otros cinco millones más lo tienen no
saben que lo tienen
y además otros 20 millones de personas
ya han rebasado el número de 100
miligramos
por eso en resolver es de extrañarnos
que en los últimos 10 años en méxico y
en gran parte del mundo la diabetes y
las enfermedades cardiovasculares es la
causa número uno de muerte entre
nosotros
pero no solamente eso si te sube el
azúcar arriba de 100 miligramos
tienes el doble o el cuádruple riesgo de
tener un infarto
y estás en la posibilidad de estar en el
grupo de las personas que ocupan el
primer lugar de ceguera en méxico la
diabetes
el primer lugar de que una persona le
amputen algún extremidades
o que necesite diálisis por
insuficiencia renal
en nuestro país del norte cada hora se
diagnostican 5000 nuevos casos de
diabetes
y hay 1500 casos de problemas oculares
que terminan en ceguera
y en el mundo cada 30 segundos una
persona es amputada por diabetes y cada
cinco segundos una persona muere en el
mundo por diabetes
por eso es importante reconsiderar un
pensamiento alrededor de nuestra salud
las personas que tienen diabetes mueren
entre el 40 y el 60 por ciento antes de
los 60 años
y no van a vivir para contarlo
y hay que venga una frase importante de
nuestro premio nobel de literatura
octavio paz que dice
vivir bien te exige morir bien también
piensa en morir pero si vives bien vas a
tener muchos años de buena calidad de
vida
pero con este panorama tan complicado
que te estoy presentando que hacer se
puede prevenir se puede evitar
viene una frase de uno de los grandes
pensadores latinoamericanos
cubano jose martin que decía hace 100
años
la mejor medicina no es la que cura es
la que previene
cómo podemos prevenir algo que es tan
catastrófico en nuestra familia en
nuestra sociedad de nuestras
instituciones
esto empieza por el riesgo el riesgo
empieza cuando alguien en nuestra
familia ya ha tenido un problema como
éste
los invito
quién de ustedes tiene ha tenido un
familiar con diabetes papá mamá abuelo
primo hermano por favor levanten la mano
sin equivocarme estoy viendo el 90% de
la asistencia con las manos levantadas
pero qué vas a hacer si tengo una factor
genético que me puede evitar cómo puedo
prevenir qué puedo hacer para no tener
este problema
una cinta métrica puede ser la
diferencia donde puedas ver dónde estás
con riesgo
si tienes una medición de la cintura de
más de 90 centímetros estás en un alto
riesgo de tener un problema con la
diabetes
y esto lo puedes identificar y manejar
muy rápidamente y podemos verlo y con
una simple medida de azúcar y que puede
ser muy sencilla
podemos darnos cuenta
la semana pasada fue una persona con su
hijo una persona que tenía diabetes y
dice porque no lo checa también a mi
hijo 15 años siendo 10 de glucosa
cómo es posible si él es sano
hay que hacer algo tenemos que tomar
acciones tiene una actitud proactiva se
cortó el riesgo para esta persona
hace un mes aproximadamente llegó otra
señora con un señor con su hija porque
la escuela le habían medido la glucosa y
le había salido en 110 doctor vengo a
que me diga si realmente tiene problema
porque ve a mi hija que está gordita
sana hace ejercicio
pues si hay un factor de riesgo no lo
creo no puede ser vea que es que sanz
está a mí a la semana siguiente regreso
con la mamá con su hija y dijo si hay
que hacer algo no podemos dudar de la
evidencia si el azúcar está alta tenemos
una persona con riesgo y hay que muchas
veces lo que tienes que hacer es buscar
ayuda y ver quién puede considerar te
para hacer un apoyo para conseguir una
reducción en el riesgo
y es tan sencillo déjame mostrarte
[Música]
un equipo simple
una cantidad pequeña de sangre mínima
5 segundos
91 todavía todavía la voy a vivir para
contarlo
qué hacer por qué
qué se necesita para cambiar este ritmo
de riesgo
se necesitan algo que una vez le
preguntaron a albert einstein
y alberta y se le preguntaron sobre qué
era
lo más poderoso de este mundo y albert
eisntein respondió no es el vapor no es
la electricidad no es el rayo no es la
energía atómica
es la voluntad
la voluntad es lo que nos va a dar el
éxito de muchas de las cosas que hacemos
y cómo manejar esto
y esta voluntad empieza en el
tratamiento preventivo y eso significa
tomar acciones y la primera y más
importante se llama
la educación
y empieza en la escuela y en la casa
muchas escuelas en américa latina y me
consta que él zelaya se hagan acciones
preventivas
y acciones que en la asociación
latinoamericana de diabetes y que ahí
está una página de esta asociación está
sin costo todo un lineamiento para cada
grado escolar
que sirva de acciones preventivas y de
cuidado
para mantener a nuestros niños sanos
y modificar un concepto que siempre
escuchamos
hay que modificar un estilo de vida para
estar sanos y vivir bien
aquí hay que trabajar con algo más y es
generar estilo de vida
y eso se empieza en la casa y respuela
y va de la mano con cuidados
alimentarios vivimos en una época de
exceso de alimentos y eso nos permite
tener disponibilidad de alimento en
cualquier momento del día
parte de esa cultura de buena
alimentación es tres alimentos por día
no comas a deshora no comas alimentos
ricos en calorías refrescos frituras no
van para el buen funcionamiento del
organismo tres alimentos por día nada
más
y si tengo hambre doctor dile a tu
estómago que espere que llanero es hora
del alimento dale una disciplina a tu
organismo
un elemento muy importante es la
actividad física
en gran parte del mundo y en méxico más
del 80% de la población es sedentaria y
no hace ejercicio regular
esto se tiene que modificar si queremos
mantener una buena calidad de salud
porque el ejercicio te ayuda a que el
nivel de azúcar se mantenga bien
el trabajo muscular hace que se consuma
glucosa se optimiza su buen nivel de
funcionamiento de tu cuerpo
entre más músculos pongas en acción
mejor es el resultado me preguntan a
veces en el consultorio
cuál es el mejor ejercicio pues bonos y
en el ejercicio te mueve más músculos en
la natación
pero puedes hacer bicicleta caminar
correr tienes que mover el músculo
y eso te va a llegar a dar una sensación
de bienestar
el músculo activo después de cierto
tiempo va a trabajar además el ejercicio
en una acción en tu sistema nervioso
que como endocrinólogo te voy a decir
el ejercicio de forma regular libera
encefalinas y endorfinas
y que te va a dar esa sonrisa te va a
dar bienestar
y te va a dar una sensación de plenitud
física
y va a alejar de la enfermedades
en fin tienes que hacer un estilo de
vida saludable alrededor tuya de tu
familia y tenemos que ser fuente de una
nueva inspiración colectiva que empiece
contigo
y que generen una sociedad saludable
y voy a terminar con una nueva frase de
albert einstein que decía
la vida es muy peligrosa
no
por la maldad del hombre sino por
aquellos que se sientan únicamente por
saber qué pasa
a aquellos que se sienten nada más para
ver qué pasa seguramente serán los que
no van a vivir para contarlo muchas
gracias
[Música]
e